alors ça vous pendait au nez christophe
lambert on va faire une interview anti
héros est-ce que vous avez déjà insulté
une petite vieille au volant ouais
jamais non je te jure est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà barré avant que la
conseil se réveille et le problème c'est
si elle se réveille avant que tu sois
varie pas toujours eu mais question est
souvent exactement exactement
donc ouais jeux précités qui j'ai essayé
mais c'était il ya longtemps mais tu te
rappelles est ce que vous vous êtes
c'était jeudi le conseil génial parce
que j'ai rarement il est conseillé en
âgé dé quoi chez tout le monde en parle
je conseille cette carte non en fait tu
dois lui perdu car de consigne en invité
alors la carte non mais j'ai lola pas
celle-là j'ai fils de [ __ ] jamais j'ai
l'autre
attention continue l'interview anti
héros est ce que vous vous êtes déjà
excusé pour éviter de prendre un pain
dans la gueule
non non un succès l'interview en tirons
mais non mais non j'ai toujours essayé
je pense que les bagarres les points ne
sont jamais des solutions donc j'ai
toujours essayé d'éviter avant que cela
arrive
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut s'excuser
non parce que moi je ne suis fait trop
tard suivant pour ce que vous avez déjà
commandé un appareil de muscu au
téléachat en pensant que ça allait
changer votre vie
non pas au téléachat par contre j'ai une
petite salle de gym que j'utilise à peu
près une fois tous les deux ans donc
elle n'est pas très évident il est ce
que vous avez déjà essayé de masquer un
bouton avec du maquillage
ouais est-ce que vous avez déjà fait la
bise à quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez non non est ce que vous êtes
déjà quitté une fille parce qu elle
avait grossi non plus mais j'ai jamais
été avec des grosses est ce que vous
vous êtes déjà barré avant de payer
l'addition pour les abeilles et les
autres jamais vous ai déjà réclamé des
fringues gratuite en disant que c'était
pour la télé si je les ai réclamé pour
l'acter c'est parce que j'y allais mais
généralement je les rangs après vous
avez déjà citer un auteur en laissant
croire que c'était de vous alors vous
avez fait des promesses de dons une
association vous n'êtes pas tenu
norkom vous avez déjà dit à une fille
que c'était la femme de votre vie pour
la sauter plus vite
non je te jure j'aurais fait la même
interview la dharma ginola je rejoins le
oui bah on va voir sur la suivante vous
avez déjà essayé de mesurer la taille de
votre bille là franchement je veux dire
qu'ils lui bon il la mesure est moi j'y
ai pensé mais je ne vais jamais fait
pour moi d'abord je vais le dire il faut
avoir un mètre
je m'explique
c'est rare de trouver des règles de
trois centimètres et dans les rajouter
boutabout tu vois ce que je veux dire tu
crois m'être et puis tu mesures soit ça
voudra dire qu'arras m non bon bah voilà
ce qu'il a dit à mots couverts qu'il
avait une butte de 3 cm j'ai pas que
c'est ça qui l'a dit david bien moi on
l'a déjà mentionné de mesurer habitants
mais quoi s'est il est coincé
il est coincé ginola pourquoi ça fait 20
ans que vous êtes avec coraline
l'ajustement je dis non c'est sûrement
pour ça c'est même temps commence à nous
commente ces choses ce soir
ah ouais hein tu gardes alors bon donc
finalement vous n'êtes pas un anti héros
c'est un vrai héros qui s'y passe que
vous répondez non à toutes les questions
souffle habite encore c'est un anti
héros c'est un vrai héros un maire est
ce que c'est en fin de compte un mec qui
a l'humilité ne veut pas à prendre sur
lui l'héroïsme de son axe c'est à dire
il part discrètement sans dire que c'est
lui qui a fait quoi que ce soit c'est
s'aérer juste
ouais ça lui va bien d'avoir arrêté de
picoler à lui avant dernier dernière
question
baba est ce que vous avez déjà utilisé
du viagra eux
non mais j'ai souvent pensé comme ça
essayez pour voir ce que ça fait vous
savez jamais ce qu'on n'en avait pas
encore besoin mais c'est une question de
besoin les gens le prennent pour des
raisons récréative vous savez nous mêmes
ouais mais pourquoi tu veut le prendre
si t'as pas besoin d'être encore
meilleurs christ
ouais mais bon si tu veux moi je suis
très bien avec ma petite femme
oui et ça va très bien sans lui à gr il
sait qu'on n'en prendre quand elle n'est
pas là
voilà on s'est embrouillé créé par
contre par contre n'ont par contre c'est
un truc que j'ai c'est vrai oui avec
elle et auxquels je pense moins souvent
mais de temps en temps la crème de
marrons chantilly où c'est le fantasme
exactement la raison
qu'est ce qu'il dit la crème de marrons
la chantilly le truc c'est qu'on dit non
j'ai compris j'ai compris mais le viagra
je n'ai pas essayé we say yeah
j'essaierai un jour aux jeux pour le
moment pas seulement quand j'en aurai
besoin voilà c'est ce que je voulais
entendre dire là je vais comme gérard
pour des raisons récréative le viagra
c'est par un problème du tout que c'est
bien c'est pas malheureusement et du
désir un oui mais ça fait la led moins
fraîches qu un tic-tac témoins pourrais
tu me suces
bruce willis est ce que vous avez déjà
fermer votre gueule devant un flic qui
vous connaît un pv ouais
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black alors tant excuse-moi l'échec
bruce willis hockey
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black
ah non et devant un blague qui s'en
prenait à un flic est ce que vous avez
déjà fait semblant de ne pas entendre
quelqu'un qui vous avez insultés yes
alors oui vous êtes déjà évanoui
on va voir parce que nous ça nous
arrange vachement que ce soit un anti
héros quand est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des chaussettes trouées par
exemple louis nesti de sale nom est ce
que vous avez déjà exigé un cascadeur
pour une scène pourtant sans danger
ah non vous avez déjà demandé à des
techniciens de sortir du plateau au
moment où vous alliez vous mettre tout
nu vous ai déjà eu une panne sexuelle
avec une femme très entreprenante non
scénario est ce que vous avez déjà serré
la main de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il
vous détestez et qui sortait des
toilettes sans salle à belem est ce que
vous êtes déjà barré avant qu'une de vos
conquêtes ne se réveille
moi j'ai crié non seulement du doigt le
matin est ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour coucher plus vite avec elle js j'ai
déjà profité qu'une fille soit bourré
pour coucher avec ah ben oui alors vigo
est ce que vous avez déjà renvoyé une
fille chez elle parce que finalement
n'était pas assez jolie j'ai
je pense que tous les filles sont jolies
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait un enfant
à une femme sans le reconnaître je crois
pas est-ce que vous avez déjà lâché les
chiens sur quelqu'un plutôt que d'y
aller vous même excuse et déjà fait
semblant de ne pas entendre quand
quelqu'un vous traitez de petites
[ __ ] des sondages pas de problème
avec ça
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé un
cascadeur pour des scènes sans danger
des scènes de sexe par exemple je peux
vous dire que toutes les cascades sud en
effet valence et vigo lui-même qui les a
tournées est-ce que vous avez déjà
demandé les techniciens de sortir du
plateau quand vous allez vous mettre
tout nu non je crois pas est ce que
faisait déjà promis à votre maîtresse
que vous alliez quitter votre femme en
sachant que vous le sauriez pas vincent
cassel qui est effondré de parler assez
de mes choses privées
vraiment est ce que vous êtes déjà piqué
la femme d'un de vos potes belge c'est
moins grave si c'est un bug c'est vrai
est ce que vous êtes déjà barré avant
qu'une de vos conquêtes ne se réveille
si jamais il est bien
c'est un vrai héros à quoi on a vraiment
heures mais est-ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de maquiller un bouton non et
vous quand j'étais petit oui j'avais 14
ans j'avais vu la clé et je m'étais du
clae rajhi et ses théories parce
qu'évidemment pas tombé du clearasil sur
un bouton on voit plus que ça bernard
monsieur mal mandat il n'a jamais eu des
clés et les invitations
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez pas complètement est-ce que
vous avez déjà lu s'est payé une femme
au restaurant ouais
ouais est-ce que vous avez déjà citer un
auteur en laissant croire que c'était de
vous non je crois
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour faire plus vite l'amour avec elle
il est honnête je trouve ce type
formidable il dit la vérité il est
honnête il est extraordinaire voilà
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait virer un
acteur sur un tournage
non j'ai pas ce pouvoir si je l'avais je
n'utiliserai pas ouais
est ce que vous êtes déjà repris un
cadeau à une de vos ex
est-ce que vous avez déjà couché avec
une fille qui avait beaucoup trop bu
bigot et remember peut-être opportun
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu